il s'appelle michael elle s'appelle alex
a ils ont tous les deux une relation
assez inconfortable avec le système de
santé sur le pointage aux gens ce qu une
crise d'asthme
parce que j'ai plus de médicaments puis
on peut la leçon sur mon poids je vais
parce que c'est une gastro on fait
l'amour est sur mon poids
quand j'ai fait un burn-out dont on voit
quand même trouvé une façon de ramener
au point où j'avais un physio et qui
m'avait suivi qui m'avait dit leur
vraiment faire part de ton alimentation
comme ça faisait 20 ans que j'ai vendu
nos chèques des big mac lutte
c'était mal les préjugés fort comme
satin tout ton intervention qui non ça
me donne pas le goût d'avoir un lien de
confiance avec toi les deux disent avoir
subi ce qu'on appelle la grossophobie
médicale ça veut dire des préjugés
envers les personnes grosses qui ont un
impact sur les soins qui sont donnés aux
mutuelles sont pas différents du reste
de la population cantonale grossophobie
cette préoccupation là et pas seulement
partagé par des patients il ya aussi des
professionnels de la santé qui disent
avoir un malaise devant des collègues
qui ont des comportements qu'on qualifie
de grosshof hop une femme dans la jeune
vingtaine
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'elle vous
a tous les autres voies en investigation
portables ont clairement ce n'est pas
normal et c'est cette heure par son
médecin que c'est pas une mauvaise chose
parce qu'elle a des réserves en or c'est
trop compliqué une personne obèse les
toutes les personnes
c'est pourquoi pas parce qu'elle est
obèse est plus compliqué le son est le
même il devrait être le même parce que
parfois ça va plus loin que le mépris
aux impatients de 25 ans qui était très
obèses qui avait pris du poids beaucoup
dans les 12 derniers mois et puis je
l'avais vu aussi beaucoup de médecins
quand je l'examiné la seule le
diagnostic était évident la maladie où
on produit beaucoup trop de cortisone et
sait manier mortel sur la soigne pas
quand je dis aux patients monsieur vous
avez une maladie qui s'appelle comme ça
c'est pour ça que vous avez pris du poil
et il a fondu en larmes parce que au
lieu tout le monde lui disait que
c'était de sa faute qui mangeait trop
beau trop tard donc c'est un cas extrême
mais ça illustre le danger de pas
examiné les gens puissent considérer que
si les gens sont trop gros basques leur
faut une étude de plus de 300 rapport
d'autopsié aux états unis révélait
d'ailleurs que les patients qu'on
présente comme obèses avaient 65 % plus
de risque de recevoir un mauvais
diagnostic ou un accès inadéquat aux
soins de santé
la société veut pas on veut pas voir des
gens ouverts on ne veut pas de boire
deux jours avec un surplus poids mais ça
ce transfert dans le domaine de la santé
et il ya aussi l'impact psychologique la
stigmatisation qui inquiète
on sent coupable à l'intérieur tu en as
com est ancré en nous les fait que ben
oui c'est ma faute c'est de ma faute si
je suis moins qu'eric juste un déchet
quasiment le cas c'est ce qu'ont fait
sentir moi j'étais ou de voir quelle
personne envie de prendre soin d'elle
lorsqu'elle se fait taper dessus
une personne qui ne système pas aux caps
add estime de soi à moins de chances
d'adopter des comportements sains encore
moins de chances de vouloir manger une
alimentation qui lui fait du bien
vont avoir envie de bouger lutter contre
la grossophobie médicale
ça veut pas dire banalisée les risques
qu'un excès de gras corporel plus
représenté on ne doit pas banaliser
parce que dans la plupart des cas les
gens qui sont obèses sont malades à
cause de leurs objectifs ou vont l'être
dans l'avenir plusieurs professionnels
dénoncent par contre l'association
automatique qui souvent fait entre un
corps gros est encore en mauvaise santé
c'est que plusieurs études qui vont
démontrer que l'amélioration des
habitudes de vie vont engendrer une
amélioration des comptes de la santé
globale donc d'une sont des facteurs de
risque
même si le poids reste le même on a
aussi demandé la réaction du collège des
médecins du québec et on nous dit qu'on
ignorait l'existence de l'expression
grossophobie médicale personnellement le
thème du kosovo bus colossaux
je connaissais depuis hier mais on ne
nie pas le problème pour houda bercy
comme la société en général il ya des
médecins qui qui peut avoir cette
attitude discriminatoire d'eau j'ose
espérer que c'est pas la majorité puis
je suis persuadé expo la majorité mais
jeudi prochain le pas je pense que cette
question d'éducation de plus en plus
petit rappel en novembre qu'il faut agir
sans discrimination selon le code de
déontologie
et justement l'éducation la
sensibilisation c'est la pièce de
solutions qui est privilégié par tous
les intervenants
je pense important que ces gens l'osm au
courant de commence à sembler personnes
grosses parce que ben c'est quand même
récente des personnes grosses s'exprime
là dessus c'est pas de la faute des
patients s'ils sont en baisse 70 % du
poids dans une population soviétique et
2 les patients ne peuvent pas s'en
sortir seule de le fait d'enseigner ça
hein ça empêche la grossophobie les +2
sympa n'allège pas parce que ça veut
dire ça souligne l'importance de soins